I did 500 days without caffeine which
was incredibly Illuminating it reminded
me that most people are totally
dependent on their coffee intake to
facilitate their not only performance
but literally just their life and that's
not the way that it should be like when
you hear people talk about caffeine they
won't say I'm tired they'll say I need a
coffee you you can be tired and not need
a coffee if you can't function without
caffeine can you really say that it's a
performance enhancer no it's like
mandatory it's like air it's not
assisting your performance it it's
required to get you from negative back
to baseline or neutral the other thing
that constantly being reliant on
caffeine does is it papers over the
cracks of why you're tired at 11AM in
the morning every single day it
shouldn't be the case that you're tired
at 11AM